quand françois mitterrand se rend cette
année là à la roche de solutré c'est
pour lui une vieille tradition qui
remonte aux années 40
tradition familiale instauré à l'époque
avec le frère de sa femme
mais cette année là c'est 1980 et
l'ascension de la roche va prendre une
toute autre dimension populaire et
médiatique
comme chaque année depuis 1946 il a
passé l'essentiel du week end à solutré
aujourd'hui l'escaladent s'est
transformé en procession pour ne pas
dire kermesse en tout cas un rendez vous
auquel le président ne fera que de très
exceptionnel entorse il sera là ou à
proximité
chacune des 14 années de ses deux
septennats
chaque année depuis 30 ans à la roche de
solutré
comme chaque année en effet depuis 36
ans comme chaque année depuis 38 ans
françois mitterrand effectué ce qui est
devenu une sorte de pèlerinage à la
roche de solutré
c'est une tradition qui remonte 40 ans
en arrière chaque jour de pentecôte
depuis 48 ans
comme chaque année depuis 50 ans si
cette tradition attire à chaque fois
toute la presse du pays
il en fut une autre qui consistait à
accompagner la couverture de l'événement
de quelques considérations
météorologiques
comme l'an dernier le chef de l'état a
bénéficié du beau temps au général
heureusement il y avait du soleil sur
cette région où la pluie n'a pas cessé
depuis deux mois
mâcon et ses alentours sont complètement
inondée
l'an dernier il tombait des cordes il
faisait beau et chaud aujourd'hui à
solutré il faisait chaud très chaud
qu'en saône et loire l'autre
incontournable de l'événement c'était
l'énumération des personnalités
présentes lors de cette ascension des
amis des ministres ceux qui étaient les
deux à la fois fidèle parmi les fidèles
jacques lang que vous voyez au côté de
charles hernu était de la promenade
cette année mais aussi plusieurs de ses
ministres
lang hernu fillioud française qui est
comme toujours le président n'était pas
seule à accomplir le pèlerinage annuel
jack lang ministre de la culture georges
kiejman nouveau ministre de la
communication en 1992 là c'est peut être
agacé sans doute ou simplement désireux
de revenir aux origines familiales et
paisible de ce pèlerinage françois
mitterrand pose un lapin aux
journalistes et au public
infidélité sans précédent à la roche de
solutré à solutré aujourd'hui on n'a
rien vu venir pour tous
l'attenté aura duré toute la matinée à
midi coup de théâtre le cortège
présidentiel apparaît au loin mais il se
dirige vers une autre roche celle de
vergisson entorse à la règle
pied de nez à tous les suiveurs pour une
première résultat une demi heure de
promenade présidentielle au calme et
dans l'intimité les années suivantes
françois mitterrand renouera avec la
tradition en 1995 malade et fatigué il
ne fera que quelques pas au pied du site
ce sera sa dernière apparition à solutré
la fin d'une tradition qu'il aura eu à
coeur de respecter pendant près d'un
demi siècle
[Musique]